I'm Dr Sanjay janja hematologist and
medical oncologist I'm here to answer
your questions from the internet this is
blood
[Music]
support first up what happens if person
gets injected with the wrong blood type
it's going to be really bad and that's
because it recognizes that protein as
foreign as a virus and it just goes
Rogue it's just like destroy destroy
destroy destroy destroy generally we
treat it with like immediate steroids
and may need to consult some very people
to try to turn the blood and get it
right we have a question from at Peyton
do we even know why we have different
types of blood like really and the
answer is we don't there's basically
eight different basic ones that are
different variations you can have a b o
or some combination and when we're
saying those letters it basically
reflects an antigen or a protein on the
surface of the red blood cells but we do
know that certain areas have more blood
types than others one of the main
reasons is because of infections and
virus es for example malaria likes to
get into red blood cells and basically
cause you all that sickness if you are
type A so you'll see more type O in
those areas because they were less
likely to die next question from Ryan
Rodriguez could blood actually spray and
or jettison from the human body as is
sometimes seen in movies shows and games
the answer is yes if you cut an artery
that pressure is higher an artery is
your oxygenated blood it's the stuff
that just got the oxygen from the lungs
and it's being pumped out it's the top
number on your blood pressure and it
carries oxygen and all the fuel and the
stuff that all your cells need to the
tissue but when you're drawing blood and
the stuff that's the veins it shouldn't
be at the pressure to be shooting out at
somebody veins are a passive more limpy
process because it's the bottom number
of millimeters of mercury on your blood
pressure and it's the blood that is now
deoxygenated it's done its job and the
red blood cells are coming back to get
more oxygen into your lungs at Garrett
sandin what the is a hematologist
dot dot dot ellipses question mark LOL a
very nerdy person usually that studies
blood when we think of blood you think
of the the red stuff and it carries
oxygen but it's actually far more than
that it's constituted predominantly by
three things red blood cells right they
carry oxygen they're like oo give me
oxygen lungs and then they go deliver it
to the rest of your body but the other
parts are white blood cells the antibody
stuff that you hear about vaccines that
live for years the third part is
platelets platelets help you clot
they're the reason that when you get a
cut it actually closes up those are
generally the three parts and then the
last one is what's called plasma and
plasma is this beautiful Harmony balance
of taking care of things when it comes
to clotting and and should you clot more
should you clot less and fight
infections point being there's a reason
that you have to do all of internal
medicine for 3 years and then an
additional one or two years in
hematology just to understand how
complicated this is next question by Dr
Moxy comms open what exactly is a
hemorrhage a hemorrhage is a general
term to just mean bleeding so you could
be hemorrhage ing technically from your
arm from a cut but we usually use it in
a colloquial sense to mean a lot at SPI
i d y y what's the difference between
red blood cells and white blood cells
red blood cells are pretty much all the
same thing in your body they carry
oxygen oxygen is the fuel on every cell
in your body white blood cells have all
different kinds there's nutrifil and
lymphocytes nutrifil are stuff that go
up with bacterial infection C and fight
things when you inhale them all the time
walking around and then you have the
lymphocytes which is all that antibody
stuff antibodies are smarter when it
comes to attacking pathogens or viruses
and stuff that's why you get vaccines
when you're young they're already
prepped and ready they're hardwired
because you gave them the wanted poster
they're kind of smarter Marines and
that's the whole concept behind vaccines
as well as just getting an infection
hosted by Champion
k448 how do scabs work scabs are
basically the evidence of of the
clotting process the moment the
endothelium that is the inner lining of
the red blood vessel when it feels
injury it sends a whole Cascade of
markers and signals and say yo I'm like
I'm I'm cut here and then the platelets
which are the things that float in your
bloodstream they're actually yellow
which is why they're found in plasma
they basically are the endothelium the
inside lining of the blood vessel
floating around and then they go to that
point of the injury and then they get
out these little tentacles and they
latch on and that's the platelet plug
and they start sending out a lot of
signals yo yo come we need to regenerate
this so when that platelet formation
starts then you start getting a blood
clot after that that is the immediate
process that's happening to quickly
restore that as fast as possible next
question from at Misha Elliot my doctor
friends what causes a blood clot and how
does it kill somebody a blood clot is
actually a complicated Downstream series
of events to make something that's hard
and put together that's clotting we need
to be able to clot right all the the
time I mean if you get a cut you need to
be able to clot it however you can have
a clot that comes out randomly this is
an example of what happens if you get a
blood clot especially if this blood
vessel was in your lungs a pulmonary
embolism and you blocked the uh blood
flow entirely to be able to get
oxygenated you're in big trouble next
question at mcco what happens when you
centrifuge blood we are basically
spinning down the blood the blood has
multiple components it has the red blood
cells that carry oxygen it has plasma it
has white blood cells that fight
infection and it has those platelets so
today we'll be using an example back
like science class of oil vinegar and
dye when you take that uniform solution
and you want to isolate your plasma you
put it into the machine and then the
centripetal force forces the densest
thing to the outside that's why it's
angled and now you have a nice
separation you have what looks like the
plasma at the top which is clear and
that's the stuff that if you get
platelets or you're getting the plasma
stuff in a hospital you'll notice the
bag is yellow and it's different than
when you're getting red blood cells next
question at I hate Trace hey Siri
there's still blood in my urine how much
is too much if you were seeing blood in
your urine that's too much even having
red blood cells that you can't see
called microscopic hematuria any much is
too much if you can see it at jacqu
derad is blood really blue in the body
the blue concept is inaccurate the veins
appear blue which are the lining or the
piping that has the blood in it U MTH n
o how does the blood pressure arm thing
work what a blood pressure cuff is doing
is assessing what pressure is your heart
pumping at the left side of your heart
is pumping blood all throughout your
body you continue to elevate the
pressure until the pressure in the cuff
is more than the pressure of your heart
pushing the blood to the end of your
fingers and then you start to come down
so you're at 180 170 160 150 140 and
then all of a sudden you hear that top
number of that strong left ventricle in
your heart able to start pushing that's
when you know your top number and
eventually the beat Fades away why
because the bottom number is the passive
way that our blood after it is done and
given the oxygen to everything it needs
to come back to the heart to get more
oxygen by deaft with many te's why do
people faint when they see blood the
reason that we pass out in general is
because if our blood vessels dilate
which is what's happening when you see
something that's scary and your brain is
not perceiving enough blood anymore so
the theory is through Evolution our
bodies learned that I'm having trouble
getting blood with oxygen and fuel to
the most important organ in my body the
least I can do is completely collapse so
I don't have to combat Newton's
gravitational law like downward next
question by Michaela Phillips at 98 kala
every time I'm on my period I'm so
confused how girls can bleed so much and
still live your bone marrow is
constantly making blood and so if you
were to check a reticul site which is a
baby blood blood vessel it's cute it's
actually bigger than than normal you'll
see that during and after your cycle
that reticulite count should be up
that's showing that your bone marrow is
spitting out and trying to accommodate
for the circumstances because your red
blood cells all only live about 90 to
120 days so it's always doing it and it
knows when you need more at Sir Jeff 32
can someone die from high blood pressure
like this is a real question the answer
is yes two times over you can die from
acutely high blood pressure which means
at that moment too much you know at all
cocaine methamphetamines because they
raise your blood pressure now the blood
pressure itself will not you know kill
someone but those blood vessels that are
taking that insult from the heart it's
200 it's 220 then if it cracks and Pops
open now you're bleeding into your brain
or anywhere else and that can cause
obviously immediate death but then over
time the reason people are so obsessive
about it is because that injury from
that flow of that blood pressure over
and over and over eventually start
causing this kind of stuff pla burdens
and a little injury and then now this
coronary artery disease or
cardiovascular disease is starting to
clog up everything and remember the way
that your heart functions your brain
functions your kidneys function all the
things that are called vital organs
start losing the amount of circulating
blood and oxygen they need to operate
correctly next question from at Mark
visy how often are New blood cells made
and what are they made from they're all
made for the most part in the same place
they are made in the same place and
that's your bone marrow when you break a
chicken bone you see that dark you know
Ruddy stuff it's in the bone within the
bone itself and they're basically
prompted by stem cells and your stem
cells say hey I need some more your red
blood cells live about 90 to 120 days so
when they're getting kind of recycled in
the spleen and old you make new ones
from the bone marrow this next question
from Ari weird question does anyone know
if low white blood cell count is ever
serious if it deviates from your
Baseline and you see this massive drop
then that generally is thought to be
something to investigate or be serious
but what's crazy C is in Black Americans
and as well as some other minority
groups ranges we have for normal are
actually based for the most part on
Caucasian Americans from like the 1980s
it took 10,000 healthy people and were
like you look really healthy let's see
what your number is and said this is
what we consider normal so up to one out
of three to one out of five black
Americans will actually repeatedly look
low on the white blood cell count but
more specifically on the neutrophils
that's something to be said about ranges
so if you're ethnic and you're using the
range of someone in America of what our
cuto offs are realize that we only know
normal by sampling people and saying you
look healthy and this is what we think
is normal at Enoch nans what are the
signs of leukemia leukemia is when
something has gone very wrong very very
wrong in your bone marrow your bone
marrow has like a hierarchy and pecking
order you have just the number of cells
that you need to differentiate and
mature and grow what leukemia happens is
it's not regulated anymore cancer means
unregulated cell growth if you have a
acute leukemia marked exhaustion
marketed fatigue your blood count is
like super low uh and you may be losing
weight and you're exquisitely sensitive
to getting infections and often times
you'll notice you start getting you know
spots of little pinpoint red dots out of
nowhere because your platelets are so
low at Gina 2 Imron why do mosquitoes
prefer some people but wouldn't bite
others one of the main things that
they're theorizing is if you have more
CO2 which is bicarbonate in your blood
apparently mosquitoes can kind of almost
sense in the blood that has more
bicarbonate also depending on what type
you have supposedly that may kind of
Trigger or have a predeliction on what
mosquitoes favor but the truth is it's
quite complicated and we all wish that
Noah had just slapped those two
mosquitoes well that's all the questions
I really hope you learned something and
appreciate the blood system more we'll
see you next
time